[Applaudissements]
une cérémonie à la maison blanche qui
résonne comme une victoire diplomatique
est un cadeau de campagne pour donald
trump dans le rôle d'artisan de la paix
en pleine campagne pour sa réélection
le président américain a accueilli ce
mardi plus de 700 invités sur la pelouse
de la maison blanche pour assister à la
signature de l'entente historique entre
israël les émirats arabes unis et le
bahreïn une signature entre le premier
ministre israélien benyamin netanyahu et
les ministres des affaires étrangères
émirati et du bahreïn avec donald trump
en grand témoin tout un symbole oui mais
les bienfaits de la paix que nous
faisons aujourd'hui seront énormes
d'abord parce que cette paix finira par
s'étendre à d'autres états arabes et
qu'elle pourra finalement mettre fin au
conflit israélo-arabe une bonne fois
pour toutes
and one
pourtant cette cérémonie mise en scène à
la maison blanche n'a pas vocation à
mettre fin aux guerres qui se
poursuivent au moyen-orient
n'apportant pas de réponse au conflit
israélo palestinien
ces accords officialiseront plutôt la
normalisation des relations déjà en
train de se réchauffer entre l'état
hébreu et les deux pays arabes
si les signataires qualifient ces
accords comme ceux de l'espoir et de
l'optimisme
les palestiniens grands absents dénonce
un coup de poignard dans le dos de la
part de leurs états frères en vue des
présidentielles de novembre
donald trump et son entourage ne manque
pas de souligner la dimension pacifique
de cette signature nous sommes ici cet
après-midi pour changer le cours de
l'histoire
après des décennies de division et de
conflits nous marquons l'aube d'un
nouveau moyen-orient grâce au grand
courage des dirigeants de ces trois pays
nous faisons un grand pas vers un avenir
où vivront des personnes de toutes les
confessions et de tous les milieux
alors que les émirats arabes unis ont
indiqué qu'israël n'irait pas plus loin
dans son plan d'injection des colonies
de cisjordanie
benyamin netanyahou lui insisté sur le
fait que ces annexions était à ce stade
seulement suspendu et restaient en
discussion